[Music]  time for et social study your quick look  at what the stars are posting online  country singer Thomas Rhett took to  Instagram to share with fans the moment  he and wife Lauren found out the gender  of their babies  [Music]  Madonna shared a video of her newly  adopted twins Stella and Esther adorably  singing twinkle twinkle little star and  Teen Mom 2 star Jenelle Evans posted  that sweet video to Instagram a fiance  David Easton curled up with their  newborn baby girl and her seven-year-old  son Jace  meanwhile Ashlee Simpson took to the  gram to wish her pops Joe a happy  birthday with this cute snap kissing her  dad  sweetly captioning the pic you're my  sunshine and Lindsay Lohan revealed she  wants to sing again as Ariel the thirty  year old actress posted this  side-by-side with the Disney Princess  writing quote Disney approved that  [Music]